a generation in population that doesn't
want to come back to work a generation
largely generation that has a different
definition of what full-time employment
is like who says I have to work
full-time for one company I can work
full-time for two companies when we pay
you your full salary and we pay you
benefits you can't work for anybody else
why not I mean I don't think that's been
resolved of what the definition of
full-time employment is especially when
I don't keep normal hours what the
definition of of the value of a job is
like some people want to have ambition
and they want to move move up the ranks
and some people don't just want to get
to work and make a bit of money and pay
their bills and they don't really care
about progress of you know they want to
do good work and be treated well they
still take pride in their work they're
not lazy they just they're not career
Hunters you know the way to combat all
of these things or manage all of these
things look the list goes on is to be
very open and honest about it to have a
conversation and to make the implicit
explicit when you take implicit tensions
and you make those tensions explicit
even if you don't have resolution it at
least normalizes it so to say things
like these are strange times where we
don't really
know what full-time employment means we
say to the team or I know that we're
many of us are still struggling with
like what kind of careers do we want and
do we even want to work here do I even
want to work hard or what does that even
mean and just having the conversation
out loud tells everybody like I know you
know you don't have to hide these things
I know it's like kid our kids can't
imagine that we ever got drunk or
anything anything when we were younger
you know it's like they forget that we
were young at one point like all of the
idiot things that they do we've done all
those things when you make it loud it
allows for discussion to happen